Welcome to another edition of Truth or Fail where our demographics analysts have told me...
...that the audience for this show really enjoys Sherlock Holmes.
And hey, I love Sherlock Holmes as well, but I'm not just talking about the BBC Sherlock...
...or other recent interpretations that we may not want to go into with Robert Downey Jr.
As much as I love those, there is an amazing history behind...
...Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's legendary literary creation.
So today, we're going to delve into all things Sherlock and maybe, if you're lucky,...
...I'll even throw in a question about the Cumberbatch show.
So, put on your deerstalker cap and cape and as always, pay attention to the clues.
Let's play.
Round number one: Origins.
Fact number one: Sherlock Holmes may be fictitious but Arthur Conan Doyle hinted many times...
...during his lifetime that the detective was based on a family friend named Dr. Charles House.
House was actually a medical doctor but he loved detective work...
...and often assisted the local police in solving crimes.
And yes, he's the reason that we had a Dr. House on the popular television series...
...or it could be fact number two.
Sherlock Holmes is the subject of 56 short stories and four novels by Conan Doyle...
...and all but four of the stories were narrated by Dr. John Watson:...
...Holmes' friend, assistant and occasional roommate.
But did you know that in all those stories Watson's first name is only mentioned three times...
...and never by Holmes himself.